I have this huge urge to be the best
person that I can be okay so if I look
at like my top three goals in life
number one is to make myself the best
person I can be and have kids who are
greater than me number two is love I
think love is the most important thing
in life and the more you give it the
more you have to give it's like fire you
light a flame and you can then light
another one without extinguishing the
original one Renewable Energy
Engineering energy cannot be created or
destroyed but love can it's like a jug
where as you pour of it The Jug gets
bigger has more water in it so I think
Love Is Magic so maximize love in my
life whether it be with my friends with
my users with my kids with my partner
whatever it might be and number three is
to create as much value in the world as
possible and Elevate the collective
quality of life and I see creating value
as a function of love it's how you love
on someone who you've never met before